[Música]
es un espacio donde las mujeres pueden
venir consumir de manera segura les
ofrecemos además de la información de
cómo tener una inyección segura les
ofrecemos los insumos ellas llegan y les
entregamos el material jeringas agua
inyectable Las toallitas al coladas todo
el material que requieren para una
inyección segura ellas aquí consumen
Esta es una de las cabinas
[Música]
sí estás muy fuerte e incluso me llegué
a Cómo se dice agarrar una
sobredosis este y me pusieron la
ampolletas para traerme para atrás
porque era Era muy fuerte pues
usé la misma cantidad que usaba antes y
pues no tenía esa cosa frente al hilo y
pues éramos muy fuerte para mí
[Música]
entonces antes de que de que ellas
consuman o ellos les les podemos decir
sin sustancia tiene fentanilo por
ejemplo
[Música]